I think the values is the key thing so I
mean in if it's in the 20 the 1920s
um there are
well actually there's a few kind of
events so
one thing is just that the basic
understanding of the Greenhouse Effect
and warming from carbon dioxide is 1896
was the first quantitative estimate and
it was surprisingly good actually
um at the time people didn't appreciate
just how much carbon we were going to
emit into the atmosphere but I actually
think that with like further work
that should have been predictable
because it's just based on an
exponentially going
to started doing is like imagine if we
got started with the kind of campaign to
be concerned about climate change
um you know 60 years earlier or 50 years
earlier than we've done you could have
engaged in like very gentle long-term
planning that like people wouldn't have
um opposed perhaps it's a carbon tax
that's like one penny of per ton to
begin with and then it just virtually
scales up over time you could have
normalized these ideas and it could have
been like a pretty painless I think we
could have just like essentially avoided
the problem of climate change we would
have been acting on more speculative
evidence
um but
I think the gains from acting early
would have outweighed the you know
the losses from having to act on more
speculative evidence and so I actually
kind of see a lot of the issues I'm
pointing to such as around engineered
pathogens and artificial intelligence
it's kind of like that
you know climate change in the 1920s or
something
so that's one thing
um then secondly is uh priorities that I
still think are important which are um
uh ensuring good values thinking about
future technological developments
um
thinking about uh
the like how bad the risk of War could
be
um now it's true that as things went
like obviously it was already enormous
attention on you know trying to stop the
rise of
um fascist Germany and so in that case
it's not so clear
you know maybe there would have been
extra effort on that or something but
all that it was a lot
um but still I think that would have
been helpful still I also think that
like more people thinking about that at
the time
um potentially even having a longer on
thought on
the potential for Atomic weapons to just
radically change society
um
you know again just more people kind of
working on these issues and taking them
seriously it seems would have resulted
in a better outcome I think
yeah like the the example of climate
change is an interesting one
now like bringing us back to today what
do you think we can actually do now to
positively impact the long-term future
uh yeah I think there's many things to
do
um the things that are most factorable
and I'm most excited about yet most
neglected are within the area of
pandemic preparedness where
um you know this was actually one of the
things that really made me uh
endorse the kind of long-termest
approach like really on a gut level is
just seeing that people who are bought
into these ideas were worrying about you
know Global pandemics
um for many many years encouraging
people to go into these areas and
um funding them since about 2016. there
was a kind of community prediction
um that there would be a pandemic uh
with at least 10 million dead in this
was in 2016 in the following decades but
like one in three probability on this
and then it's just well it happened it
was enormously costly and um you know
this enormous tragedy and it just made
me think like look we just could have
been preparing way more for you know
allegedly unprecedented events but that
are actually like foreseeable
um and I think we can do this again and
now here's the second part of it after
covet
what response has there been well after
9 11 There Was You know it's billion
dollars foreign interference there was
um
you know a new Department of Homeland
Security in the US enormous kind of
Global Response and after covid-19 it's
been essentially crickets but there are
things that we can really do so early
detection so you just all around the
world have sites that are monitoring
Wastewater screening that Wastewater for
all sorts of
um all DNA in the sample apart from
human DNA is there any new pathogen
that's like exponentially increasing
then we can respond to pandemic like as
soon as it arises
and then a second technology I'm
particularly excited about is low
wavelength light that
um you can install in light bulbs and it
kind of sterilizes our room essentially
so in just the same way that you know
when I drink without water that has been
coordinated to cure it from
to stop it from uh giving me diseases
but yet the air I believe is entirely
like unpurified
whereas with research and development we
could both ensure efficacy safety and
also get the cost down we could try to
have
um this sort of lighting and sword and
light bulbs all around the world as part
of building codes we could prevent the
next pandemic while also getting rid of
most conspiracy diseases
and that's just something that's like
look it's on the table for us we
actually have a really pretty good
understanding of like how viruses work
and what we could be doing to protect
against them
it's so it's so much on the table and
and I think that's one of the things
that that made me quite a bit more
pessimistic really in uh the last years
like I
I think I would have expected that at
some point we might uh we might have a
pandemic
I think like the the public health
experts the epidemiologists they were
very clear that the the risk is is
considerable
so that wasn't that surprising but the
fact that we lived through an entire
pandemic
23 million people I think
um dead that's kind of the current
excess mortality estimate like obviously
everyone spent
um all of these months
um indoors all the lockdowns that that
we suffered through
and that we are now uh slowly getting to
the other side of that
and we're doing almost nothing to
prevent the next pandemic that I would
have really not expected uh two years
ago yeah yeah me neither I was I would
have expected a much larger response
um from the governments of the world
um and so in the United States there was
um a bill called the Apollo program oh
part of buildback better was funding the
public events like 70 billion dollars
would have been made enormous difference
to the chance of the next pandemic
um and yep just got completely stuck
down because there was no one really
championing it um in Congress
um I know less about the UK but it's
also that I'm not
you know there's nothing I'm kind of
aware of yet in terms of like really
major programs because also globally I
mean just
economics just you again view yourself
into this like you mentioned to begin
with
um
even just from the perspective of you
know people in Europe and people in the
United States even if they only they
don't care about even their children
they just care about themselves they
don't care about people you know the
global poor who will be most affected by
a pandemic
um
even just on those grounds it makes
enormous sense to be investing what is
globally tiny amounts of money and it's
yeah it's still not happening and so I
think we just yeah really need to
campaign for that
yeah we need to campaign for it but I
mean these days the effective altruism
Community increased so much in in size
so many uh smart young people that are
part of that Community
um that you helped to start funding has
increased a lot
um
and I think the effective altruism
Community was good in pointing towards
the risks of future epidemics way before
the pandemic
but what would you think were the big
successes of the effective altruism
Community during the pandemic
so during the pandemic
um I do think it's like there's
definitely a lesson for humility there
where I think yeah the EA community did
much better at forecasting what was
going to happen rather than compared to
like actions that really made a big
difference so
um there was a significant amount of
um
you know advice to governments about
kind of uh locking down earlier rather
than later
um as a result of um
uh
you know actually understanding how bad
this was gonna get
um and I think plausibly that led to
um
you know many thousands or maybe tens of
thousands
um of life saved uh
there was some other things I mean you
had this like
in my view you had one of the best
coping responses completely pivoting
your entire organization in order to
provide the world's best data so that
governments could make more informed
decisions
um there's also a project that was just
giving um individuals advice called
mikeclakova.org that does very well just
so people can know like what's the size
of the risks from the different daily
activities
um there was a project that got set up
called one day sooner that was um
assigned to get a kind of human
challenged Style
um set up where you know the 60 000
people volunteered and said look I'm
like young and like relatively healthy
Cove it will put a small risk to me I
volunteer to
um have a 50 50 chance of being infected
so I will get a vaccine 50 50 chance of
being infected
um that would have enabled us if those
had been able to go ahead that would
have enabled us
um to have rolled out the vaccine kind
of months in advance and that would have
been hundreds of thousands of lives
saved
however the main thing I think is just
man I really wish we'd done more like I
wish you'd done so much more earlier so
that perhaps if we'd been pushing for
human challenge Styles like years before
we actually could have had the
regulation in place such that you could
quickly do that in an emergency
situation rather than what ultimately
happened was that it took so long to
convince policy makers that by the time
the first
controls the first human challenge style
occurred
um
we already I think had
um approved the kind of vaccines
um and it had been you know safety had
been demonstrated by observational
studies so
and and I mean yes yes I agree with you
I think the the
where more opportunities to actually be
helpful during the pandemic and um it's
a lesson in humility and it connects to
a bit of a larger point I think the
effect of altruism
um 10 years ago when when you and others
initiated this movement was very much at
home in the global Health Global
development space and there you have the
big opportunity or the big advantage
that you can learn very quickly you can
trial interventions
um from vaccines to Medical Treatments
to cash transfers and you can see what
works and what doesn't and then you can
focus on those things that work and
scale them up now if we hope to impact
the far future
these Trails will be very long
and it's much harder to actually uh to
actually learn what works and what
doesn't
and then given
that one of the key concerns for the
future is the pandemic and maybe
um
the effect of altruism Community didn't
do as well as as
um we would have wished
how worried are you about this lack of
feedback and maybe this quite poor
feedback
from this from this
closest case to to an actual big future
risk that we now just suffer through
uh yeah so I think a couple of things so
I think
um
one is that uh
one is that as soon as you start to
accept the kind of just the model in my
view model fact that like future people
really matter and it's like this huge
feature ahead of us then
um
then we have like failure reflect
through feedback from anything we do so
it can be like helping people in the
short term and like okay we can be sure
we're helping people in the short term
but how does that come how does that
impact the very long term
um
it would be kind of negligent to just
like ignore that all together but then
we've got to say like actually for most
of the impact we're having because I
think most of the impact of anything we
do in the short term most things we do
in the short term and over the long term
it means we're having to just you know
make our best guesses or say we don't
know
a second though is just
um again this kind of Distinction of
like thinking long term and acting
near-term where
there are things we can do that do have
feedback loops so again we have a pretty
good understanding of you know the
mechanisms of viral transmission so we
can build uh early monitoring Wastewater
system
um we can see like does that work is
that effective at doing this kind of
more navo Target this like shorter term
Target of just is it picking up
pathogens is it detecting new pathogens
similarly we can like um see whether low
wavelength lighting is working because
the number of people having colds with
the use like an awful lot so you can
have like feedback in the short term and
then like what's the link between that
and the long term well there
um you know there you do have to rely
more on arguments considerations the
kind of easiest case I think of
something in the short term having very
long-term impacts is human extinction
where you know if all other species
Extinction too but focusing on human
beings like it just is the case that
like if human beings go extinct we're
never coming back from that and so we
just know that that's something that
would have like this extremely long-term
impact it would impact like however long
Humanity's life expectancy would
otherwise be
but then the final thing I'll say as
well is just
um
the main criticism that uh effective
altruism when focused on kind of global
health and development had was look
you're just focused on what you can
measure
and
um you know there's this story it
actually comes from 15th century Turkish
and
um setlist called
uh the dean I think
um which is about okay there's a Splunk
and they're looking for their keys and
they're looking for the keys kind of
under the light of a sleep lamp and
someone comes out and says look uh why
you like are your keys like under the
light but not post why are you looking
there and they say oh no that's not
where my keys are but that's where the
light is
and people would you know use that
analogy and argue against and say look
you should not be focusing on the things
that easy to measure the most important
things are going to be much harder to
measure you just got to make your best
judgments and so you can see this as a
kind of response to that
um where uh
where we're saying look yeah we're
trying to focus on the very most
important things sometimes it's just
really hard to know if you're making any
progress in the case of like reducing
the risk of a third world war nuclear
war I think it's just it is just very
hard to know if you're making progress
does that mean we shouldn't try I think
probably not but it is certainly like if
there's one can expect them within
effects of altruism it's probably on
this Dimension there are some people who
are like look if we don't have good
feedback loops I'm literally pessimistic
that we can make any progress and those
people you know still focus on global
you know the sorts of bed nasty worming
um things that are like making
measurable impacts in the short term and
that's still scaling enormously like
um again closing in on a billion dollars
per year
um and then there's the people who say
look I'm willing to like accept maybe
I'm not going to have as reliable
feedback loops but then I'm focusing on
what I think is is really the most
important thing so
right right there are these two extremes
uh where do you fall yourself in this on
this question
um what is the Right Mix uh for for the
EA Community more broadly or for anyone
who wants to do good
um should they put all of their effort
into Global development or all of the
effort into long-termism so I mean I
think any individual person will need to
you'll need to make a bet unfortunately
because someone who's working half time
on
uh malaria and half time on
um nuclear war or something it's
probably not going to be as effective as
you know if you've got two people one
one specializes in each
um
I'm really in favor of like an effective
autism community that has a diversity of
different World Views and a diversity of
different areas that it's focusing on
um and that's for a few reasons
um uh but one of which is just that I
expect us to learn a lot more again over
the next kind of coming decades and I
think like
a community that has a diverse array of
focuses
um it's just going to be one that's much
more adaptable over time
um but then for me me personally
um I'm like more in the focus on what's
most important Direction
um although I definitely feel the worry
about kind of
um
I feel the worry about the lack of
feedback effects and so on and within
you know that does mean that I think for
the example pandemic preparedness where
I think we can be a lot more we can be
really very confident we're making
progress on this at least often
um compared to some other issues you
know like using this nuclear war it does
make me a lot more excited about it it
makes me see that as the kind of lowest
hanging fruit within
um long-termest work
right like
and how do you think about this going
forward is there some is there some
moment is there some uh signal some
heuristic that you're looking out for
where you would think okay we're
actually on the wrong on the wrong track
with uh focusing on long-termism is
there is there actually like
we we actually don't succeed in in
really reducing the the risks we're not
really succeeding in uh improving the
values that future Generations might uh
inherit from us is there some is there
some moment that you would wait for
where you would say
I would want to achieve
uh that's that this by by that point in
time and if we don't succeed then um I
really have to revise my my thinking on
long-termism
sure yeah so I mean I think there's two
ways I could advise my thinking one is
certainly just more kind of
philosophical theoretical arguments just
about the value of the future versus new
term and
um uh you know some of the arguments I
give in the book and what we have the
feature could certainly
um
I could certainly be convinced out of
that
um and then a second
yeah I think
I mean one area that's of particular
interest is the field of
AI alignment
um so the risk is that we might build
um increasingly powerful AI systems but
does not have a very good understanding
of like
uh what they're going to do and
especially as AI systems get more and
more powerful start to act more like
actors in the world rather than just
tools it becomes increasingly important
first to be able to actually predict how
they will act in the world
um this is an area where in one
important sense you do get feedback
systems so the field of AI alignment is
thinking okay how can we build AI models
that are helpful harmless
um uh and honest
um and so I can have like a language
model something that like produces text
can engage in like basic uh conversation
and I can say Okay I want to train this
such that it never lies
so it never tells me something
false well something that false that uh
it I can have evidence like knows the
answer to and so we can do that that's
something where we can actually like get
um like positive feedback on
uh if it was the case that in kind of 10
years time and this is field is like
lillianus infancy
um and it's still up for debate I think
kind of how much progress on the object
level has been made so there's been a
lot of like clarifying like
understanding of the
um issues uh
but in terms of like oh yeah this paper
has made this like really important
Advance on the alignment problem
um uh I don't think we're quite there
yet
and so if in the if it was 10 years time
and that's still true
um that would be a pretty
um
yeah I think like that would be a pretty
harsh blow to that as a field at least
and so then you would need to
pandemics and just kind of there's just
so many things we can do to reduce the
risk that um
I guess
and no it could have again be work we do
all these things and they just keep
failing and they keep failing
um or maybe we just keep learning that
there's like surprising kind of uh
backfiring effects or something
um for pandemics I think that's kind of
less likely
um but it could be the case that if in
all the cause areas that we think are
kind of most important by long-termest
lights
um they
we just keep finding like 10 years time
we've made almost no progress on it then
yeah I would
I'd really want to be think yeah then at
that point I'd be like really think
rethinking things again it might still
be all like philosophically justified by
um how things ultimately get like
benefit the long-term future but um the
set of priorities would be like very
different and might look a lot closer to
commonsensically kind of building or
flourishing societies